[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm going to
introduce with Iranians that are
confirmed to take place in a season 8
premiere this radiance will take place
where it all started at Winterfell
summer long abated some expected and
some tense so let's just jump in it in
the end of season seven some main
characters are already in Winterfell
while most of them are heading towards
the eatin area to rhyme John and Danny
with their entire crews which includes
quite a bit of the main characters
earned both heading for white Harbor
with the unsullied or they land and
needed to check in the kingsroad and
then ride together to Winterfell
arriving within the fortnight or at
least that was the plan in the end of
season seven in my prediction video
regarding season 8 I predicted that all
this would likely take place of screen
and we'd only see them arriving an
interval in the season 8 premiere which
has been confirmed a few weeks ago with
the very first teaser of the final
season with most of the characters being
at the same place we expect many
Iranians and first meetings to take
place John reuniting his friends and
family dana meeting the Starks etc and
that's exactly what we are going to get
a series of new reunions taking place in
the very first episode as the first
official teaser confirmed it in case you
have not been caught up with the news a
few weeks ago Entertainment Weekly
provided the first exclusive look at
what's to come in the next and final
season of Game of Thrones
these are includes a detailed
description of the opening scene the
largest battle scene ever filmed for not
only gaming journalist Bart for the
television in general and the mysterious
scene from the very finale all of which
I already discussed in my previous
videos the focus here is on the opening
scene that sees the arrival of John and
Dana video crews have interval which is
said to be similar to King Robert's
arrival in series premiere this episode
will be an episode full of reunions so
if you've been injured for some of your
favorite characters to finally reunite
good news for getting into the very
first episode of the final season it is
breaking news of the opening scene being
and winter Fowler John and Danny are
arriving with their crews describing it
as an episode full of reunion some major
unions have basically been confirmed now
in part one I brought unions between
John and his family with the tense one
being with Sansa who said not to be
thrilled the jumpin and into his fancy
new Targaryen girlfriend at least at
first beside reuniting with his family
in part 1 January nights with his
friends out of which the most important
is with Sam who has the life-changing
information waiting for John John all
serene add to this dire wall whose
current location has been confirmed to
be Winterfell while his appearance was
confirmed by directors and visual
effects supervisor
however it's not only John
who arrives an interval and suddenly his
minions say discussed in part one
there's also centered the Hound Clegane
who is part of Jon's crew I brought to
his rhenium it's an Santeria perhaps the
only two people he cares about
there's also Guinea and our union which
could potentially be the first step
forward in dug into his father's Robert
Baratheon's promised or his father Ned
Stark in season 1 finally being
fulfilled if you have not seen the first
part of confirmed reunions I highly
suggest you to do so anyway it's not
that you know that these as well as the
following Iranians have been confirmed
by the first teaser of the final season
the first screening I'd like to discuss
in this varies between Arya Stark and
spider varies among go ladder Indians
this is the only one that's not
long-awaited or that much discussed but
it's Iranian that could mean an end for
various very scenario never shared the
scene but it will certainly saw it
shattered by living at the same place
during the first season why could this
reunion be the end for heirs
why would Ari or kill the spider for the
same reason she killed Littlefinger for
betraying her father back in the very
first season while cat chasing training
exercise Aria found her way into the
dungeons under the red key where she
sees the dragon skulls but more
importantly overhears fairies who plus a
theory about the future war between the
Starks and the Lannisters where Smith is
Allah who secretly harbours the less
remaining Targaryen heirs and who
arranged the wedding of Danny to Khal
Drogo all of which was versus plain very
sim form salerio have the new hand of
the King Ned Stark now has the same book
that his predecessor read and has met
Robert's bastard son ginjury the same
evidence which led John rein to discover
the truth about Queens sources children
Hillary suggests the possibility that
the same fate may be followed Sarkis did
his predecessor but very states that Ned
is not the same man as the rain was
versus earlier that the conflict between
the Lannisters and the Starks will soon
escalate into civil war
Blair protests that the war will not
serve their purpose right now since Khal
Drogo is not yet ready to send his army
of the tracky to invade Westeros for the
Targaryens
where's protests that there is no way of
delaying the incoming conflict so the
track he must be urged to move faster
are you basically overheard various
plotting of having the Starks and the
Lannisters fight each other so the
Targaryen scoot coming down the unstable
Westeros making their conquest far
easier or you kill Littlefinger because
all his crimes against her family
because he betrayed her father and said
the war between the Starks and Lancers
but Arya now reunites with a man who had
the same plans
but one would say but very tried to save
Ned how did he be trained yes very
seized one who talks Ned into confessing
his false crimes in order to be allowed
to take black and live his days with his
son on the wall framing it as being for
his children's sake while in fact he did
not care for Ned nor his family
very simply warning that to confess take
the black can avoid the death because as
we know from a number heard conversation
between where's in Illyria they were not
ready for all-out war yet and Ned's
death would indeed spark one where
explained to setup war between the lines
and Wars but he did not want an outright
war for the time being because Dan is
pregnant and he knew that Khal Drogo
would never start a campaign before the
birth of his child
so where is basically tried to prevent
it from dying because he did not want to
war just yet but eventually he planned
to set up war between the Starks and the
Lannisters when they needed Trek he were
ready to invade Westeros various could
say that he tried to save net from dying
but Ari overheard very spotty metal area
she knows very splendid set up war
between the wolves and lions crimes lo
finger dead against her family crime
solo finger paid with his life another
Indian I'd like to talk about is not as
intense or intense at all really perhaps
one of the union's that most fence a lot
to finally see is the one between sense
and Tyrion once a married couple the two
will surely be happy to see each other
alive and well after a long time Tyrion
was the only Lannister that cared for
Sansa and actually tried to make her
time at King's Landing a bit better by
protecting her from King Joffrey
numerous times and by being kind to her
all the time it did not take sin so long
to realize that Tyrion is not like his
family she quickly grew to trust them
and liked him as a person they have both
been through some rough times since then
and one or two scenes between those two
would be great to see if I'd have to
guess I'd say that Tyrion will as sensor
how she escaped King's Landing and how
they managed to see it through a little
fingers game while we are all excited
for the big reunions there's plenty of
let's call it minor in Ian's there are
also going to be very interesting such
as Jorah Mormont reuniting with Lyanna
Mormont and Sam
this episode is full of minions but it's
also an episode full of first meetings
out of which some are said to be intense
such as the stark sisters meeting Danny
about which I talked in the first part
however this will not be Danny's only
tense first meeting as beside the stark
sister she's also going to meet Justin's
best friend Samuel Tarly whose father
and brother Shi burned alive during this
past season anyway
it's not only danny john and their crews
that are heading from King's Landing to
Winterfell
there's one more man that's heading
north to help the living win the Great
War yes Jamie Lannister whose arrival at
Winterfell might not have been confirmed
by the season a teaser but it's safe to
say that he'll arrived there sooner or
later John Danny and all our main
characters who are travelling with them
will arrive at Winterfell in the season
8 premiere but Jamie who's unlike them
been traveling on his horse instead of a
boat will likely arrive a bit later
probably in Episode two Jaime will have
a huge rhenium it's quite a bit of
characters there Styrian and Brienne who
will likely be happy and proud that
Jaime's honor his pledge well Danny
might be a little suspicious about his
intentions when she finds out Cersei
does not plan to aid him in the great
war to come of course Jaime's most
important reunion is the one with brain
stark as we all know back in the first
season Jaime was caught having an
intimate relationship with Cersei by
brain to keep bran from reporting what
he had just witnessed which would have
resulted with Jaime Cersei and all their
children being executed Jaime had to
push bran out of the tower window
costing bran the ability to walk and
rendering him a [ __ ] the question we
all have regarding this reign in his
hovel brain react at first glance would
assume that brain would react angrily
since that's the man who almost killed
him the last time they saw each other
but it most likely will not be the case
Jon Snow invited the Lannisters to come
and support living in the wars to come
Jaime agreed any honor his pledge
meaning that no harm would John do to
him nor would he allow anyone else to do
so meaning otário most likely will not
kill Jaime as soon as she finds out
Jaime attempted to kill her sibling
however it's on the stark reaction we
are looking for out of this Iranian it's
brands in the fourth episode of the
seventh season brain stated that his nut
bran stark any more but rather the
three-eyed Raven what does that mean it
means that he will not sentence Jaime to
death nor will he allow anyone else to
do him any harm rather than sentencing
Jaime to death bran will in my opinion
reveal to everyone the real truth behind
Jaime's so-called betrayal or Dana's
father the Mad King
Jaime should not be mocked and called
the Kingslayer but rather the hero and
the savior of the city as Jaime killed
Mad King just because he could not let
him burn hundreds of thousands of
innocent people
yes Jaime was one of the established
members of the Kingsguard under the Mad
King and his duty was to protect the
King from harm at all times
but even if Jaime decided that told
innocent people looking Landing our net
worth of killing his king he would have
still broken an oath
you are no nut you are forsaken every
vow you ever took of so many vows they
make you swear and swear defend the King
obey the King obey your father protect
the innocent defend the weak what if
your father despises the king if the
King massacres the innocent it's too
much much what you do you're forsaking
one vow or another the Kings guard is an
elite group of seven knights were
religiously influenced by the code of
chivalry and honor this code states the
Knights must defend the weak and
innocent so even if Jamie instead of
killing him did led the Mad King burned
capital to the ground along with all
innocent people in it Jamie would have
still broken an oath so seemingly an
intense reunion which something could
Envy Jamie's death will likely be just
the opposite Jamie and his great deeds
will finally get the recognition he and
his act against the Mad King deserve not
the traitor not the Kingslayer but the
hero and the savior of King's Landing in
its people very happy guys confirmed
reunions of the final season of Game of
Thrones and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace
you